is it true that when you were 9 years
old you used to write jokes and send
them to The Tonight Show and that Johnny
Carson actually read two of them on air
and do you remember the jokes uh yes
this is this is totally true uh uh but
it's it's a little bit I didn't it's not
like I wrote jokes they um you know I
grew up in Los Angeles and so the
Tonight Show would uh they would like go
to a local elementary school and give
them like prompts like questions and
then they would kind of we' just answer
the questions and then it was like kids
do the darnest things and they would
read the lines out so it's not like I'm
just submitting jokes like I got to make
it on it's not it's not like that it's
not like that at all I just I just
answered these questions and other kids
did too and they all got them on air but
none of them became professional
comedians so it's more interesting fact
to from my life yeah you are a father
turkey what will you say to your wife
and kids the day before Thanksgiving as
the father
turkey I know here's what I love Louis
cats
okay here are all your lion
costumes not bad